تخفى عدد من العماله الوافده في السعوديه
في مستودع يتم الدخول اليه من باب ثلاجه
السلطات كشفت الحيله واحالت العمال الى
الجهات المختصه
[موسيقى]
كانها سحابه عملاقه تداول ناشطون على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اللقطات مرعبه
لعاصفه القويه التي ضربت مصر العاصفه
تسببت بمقتل شخص واحد على الاقل
مقطع فيديو متداول للصين جائع يقتحم محلا
محل مخبوزات في مدينه فانكفورت الكنديه
الى ان اللص قرر تنظيف المحل والفوضى التي
احدثها قبل سرقه 6 قطع من الحلوى
[موسيقى]
كانه مشهد سينمائي لسياره مسرعه تصطدم
بشاحنه وتطير على ارتفاع 120 قدما في
الهواء في ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه قامت
الشرطه بمساعده السائق الذي نجا من الحادث
باعجوبه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات